امور تقلقني على المنتخب الارجنتيني في
الدور ربع النهائي ارجنتين امبارح فاز على
استراليا 2-1 بمباراه صعبه كانت الى حد ما
خصوصا بالمراحل الاخيره منها بعد ما اجي
اقول استراليا
بدات التوقعات بانه الارجنتين الى النهائي
الارجنتين ستتحقق اللقب طبعا الارجنتين
راح تلعب المباراه الجايه بربع النهائي مع
المنتخب امريكا
مع المنتخب البرازيلي بكاس عالم 2014 لما
كانت البرازيل على كل نشيد وطني نشوف
البيكا من اللاعبين ونشوف الحماس المبالغ
فيه من الجماهير في لقطه امبارح بده يحط
عليها اشاره استفهام لما صد مليانه
مارتينز الكره الاخيره بالمباراه للمنتخب
الاسترالي عبد الرحمن استراليا استراليا
اسم مقارنه بالمنتخب الارجنتيني مش اسم
كبير
وكانكانيات وكجوده لاعبين فرق شاسع ما بين
الارجنتين واستراليا لما يروحوا كماندي
على مليانو مارتينز باخر المباراه ويكون
الاحتفال بهذا الشكل بانه صوت كره بنهايه
المباراه امام استراليا بدور 16 لكاس
العالم يعني احتفال كان وكانك جبت كاس
العالم بالفوز على البرازيل بالنهائي
بصراحه احتفالات الجماهير الارجنتيني
بالملاعب احتفالات مبالغ فيها همم عواطف
زايده همم بكاء دموع مع كل انتصار مع كل
هدف حتى احتفالات ميسي بالاهداف اخر كاس
عالم وبفهم انه لازم يجيب الكاس بالنسبه
له او حا انه يجيب الكاس والارجنتين حابه
تجيب الكاس ولكن الاحتفالات مبالغ فيها
والحماس المبالغ في دائما بيخلي المنتخب
عاطفي ومتقلب وغير مستقر نفسيا هذا الشيء
اللي شفناه مع البرازيل 2014 الشحن
المعنوي الزائد عن اللزوم خطر جدا على
المنتخبات المنتخب اللي بده يحقق كاس
العالم لازم يدخل هادئ لازم يلعب مبارياته
بثقه لازم يكون جاهز انه يقدم داخل ارضيه
الملعب اداء اللي عليه ويتعامل بخبره
وبذكاء مع المباريات بكل امانه منتخب
هولندا مثلا مثال على ذلك منتخب هولندا
يتلقى هدف امور طبيعيه امور تمام تظل
مسيطر على اللعب بضل عم بطبق اسلوبه بجسمه
لحتى يجيب بهدف ثاني او ثالث ويحسب مباراه
مثل ما شفنا امبارح مع المنتخب الامريكي
بين المنتخب الارجنتيني اول ما يتلقى هدف
من مباراه السعوديه حتى الان اول ما
يستقبل هدف على طول المنتخب يعني امبارح
سجل فيهم هدف الاول من جانب استراليا
بالخطا الجول اجى ضرب بمدافعه وهكذا دخلت
بالشباك انزل برنامج الوسط بعد ذلك انهيار
انهيار بالنسبه للمنتخب
الارجنتيني وكانتو استراليا قادره انه سجل
هدف ثاني وربما الثالث وتحسب المباراه
لصالحها لذلك بالمباريات الكبرى بالمواعيد
الكبرى بالبطولات الكبرى لا يجب انك تكون
حماس زياده عن اللزوم لا يجب ان يكون عندك
حاله من ال- ال- العاطفيه المبالغ فيها
لازم تلعب بعقلانيه وبدك هذا امر اول
بيخوفني عن المنتخب الارجنتيني ثاني امر
بيخوفني على المنتخب الارجنتين هو سكالوني
اسكالوني لحد الان غير مقتنع بخيارات
الهجوميه كل مباراه بافكار هجوميه مختلفه
كل المباراه بالتوليفه هجوميه مختلفه مره
بيبدا
توليفات مختلفه ما لها علاقه ببعض ما في
شكل هجومي واضح لمنتخب الارجنتين بصراحه
مع منتخب الارجنتين لو لميسي لم يصل الى
دور 16 ولم يصل الى ربع النهائي كان لولا
وجود ميسي بالفريق ميسي هو هجوم الارجنتين
لاول مره في تاريخ الارجنتين ربما هجوم
الارجنتين يعتمد على لاعب واحد بس حتى وسط
الملعب دي بول جرينتا روح قتاليه بودي
جارد لميسي فاين ما في مشكله من الموضوع
ولكن داخل الملعب لما تكون الكره معك شاطئ
شو لعبتي اعطائه اقل كثير بصراحه من من
المتوقع من دي بولو من مهارات وامكانيه
بول همم خط الوسط عامه بالارجنتين مش مقنع
حتى خط الدفاع مش مقنع لازم الانسان عنده
مرتين يكون دائما موجود لذلك يعني خيارات
اسكالوني بصراحه عليها علامات استفهام
كبيره همم نفسيا الارجنتين مخوفني همم مش
متامل كثير صراحه انه الارجنتين تروح بعيد
كاس العالم بسبب هذه الامور لازم يكون في
هدوء اكثر ثقه اكبر مثل شفناها بالشوط
الاول امام المنتخب السعودي
وبعد ذلك الارجنتين قد تصل الى النهائي
وقد تحقق اللقب ولكن لازم يكون في تعامل
افضل من ذلك وثقه اكبر من ذلك مع
المباريات اللي جاي بالتوفيق العشاق
للمنتخب الارجنتيني خلينا نشوف شو راح
يصير في مباراه هولندا بربع النهائي وبعد
ذلك نحكم